Hey what's up guys
Welcome back
I brought you out to the Arizona desert again,
It's a little bit cold and windy today
But that's ok
Because we are here for the view
Now I found a location where apparently it's okay to break glass and that's a good thing because
I have a potentially deconstructive experiment that I've been wanting to try with this glass vaccuum chamber
Now I got the idea of using a glass cookie jar from my cousin Ty Moser
But there was a concern that it could implode violently
So the purpose of this experiment is to push the boundaries and get them to go off
So we can see when they do implode
How violent and how far reaching is that shrapnel gonna be.
So let me show you the setup we got rigged out here today
The idea is to assemble the vacuum chamber and pull 25 inches of mercury to create the strongest vacuum that we can get with this system
Then I'm going to shut off the valve to keep the vacuum pressure, turn off the pump and use a hammer to gently tap the side
So we can test just how much force it will take to get the side walls to crack and make the whole system implode
Now normally if you were to put something into a container and make it explode it will shoot shards in every different direction
Now this is a little different because we are sucking all the air out of the jar and it's creating a vacuum pressure sucking everything inside
If the structural integrity of the jar fails everything should pull in and smash in the middle
I've also a face shield and extra layers of clothing and some really thick gloves
Because even if it does smash inward I do expect shards of glass will still spray in every different direction
So lets suck out the air, grab a hammer and see how everything turns out
What does a GoPro do in a vacuum chamber we're going to find that out too
Alright guys its action time and truthfully I'm a little bit nervous cause I'm not sure what to expect so we're just going to have to jump in and find out
Let's get that gauge rising
Hey see the gauge is rising right now we're pulling about, we're coming up on 20 inches of mercury
25 inches of mercury is the highest we can go with this vacuum pump, that's the strongest vacuum we can get
This one is designed to suck out air conditioning units so it's actually a very strong vacuum
Once it hits 25 inches of mercury I'm going to turn off the valve so it maintains vacuum pressure in the jar
Then I'm going to turn off the vacuum pump so it stops making noise and we can get the full effect of the implosion
Alright it looks like its time
I'm not really sure how close I should be to this thing so I'm just gonna attack it from a distance
And start off with some gentle taps and then see exactly what it takes to crack it and make it go off.
(Taps glass)
There's a gentle tap let's try that again
Okay (Taps glass) it's actually holding up pretty well  I'm going to tap it a little bit harder
(Taps glass)
A little bit harder
I think I actually chipped the glass on that one it's still holding up
I'm going to hit it even harder
(Breaks glass)
Whoa!!!!!(Breaths heavily)
(Breaks Glass) (In Slow-Mo)
Winding up...
And there it goes.
And there's like a mist of glass dust that shoots out of the top and just blows with the wind
Even if I wasn't wearing any protective clothing I think I still would have been okay
Because any glass that would have come at me would be so low energy it would just bounce off
With with not much difficulty but it's always a good idea to be wearing safety equipment though
Check this out guys
Check this out
My proto putty looks like it's stayed intact we could just pop that off and reuse it on another jar
So looking at the damage down here guys you can see the bottom of the jar is completely annihilated
There's chunks of it over here, chunks of it over there and about a billion pieces of it over here
But I am pretty encouraged because most of it stayed in one spot there weren't any jagged pieces that shot out
And that's what I was worried about
I might have to make a new one of these lids now  because I ruined the finish that's too bad
I think it took just as much effort to crack the side wall as it would if it was at standard atmospheric pressure
If you went to the hardware store and got one of those one-foot concrete pavers and tried to smash that with a hammer
I think it would take about the same amount of force to crack that in half as it would break this jar
That's just based on feeling, that's not scientific that's just my opinion
That was the large jar how will the small jar do will it be able to withstand more force because its smaller
Let's go find out
I can't tell if this thing is actually working right now the LCD screen is completely shot
But the red light is flashing so I'm going to stick it in and see if we can get another shot
With a smaller vacuum chamber
Alright I got the vacuum pump off lets smash it
(Taps glass)
Alright I'm going to give this one a pretty good whack here
(Taps and breaks glass)
Whew!
Very nice, very nice
So every time we have a rapid decompression it seems like my GoPro just shuts off
The LCD screen has imploded
Eh it's gone completely dark and I can't see anything I'm just hoping we recovered some of that footage because that would be cool to see
If you look down here though the Proto putty gasket just popped right off
And its still in really good condition we could just pop that onto another jar and reuse it again
The only difference is look really closely here and you can see a very fine mist of glass dust so when this thing imploded
It made a cloud of dust that pops up the top and covers everything
I can't tell if the ground was shaking or if it was just the pressure wave but the camera jumped there
It almost looked like the dirt does suck up from the bottom that's really crazy
It just kinda rises and falls in the same spot
Now since we got one more small jar left let's switch things up a little bit so rather then smashing it with a hammer
Let's try lifting it up and dropping it on a rock instead
Alright we're at 25 how high do I have to drop it before this thing will break
Lets just start off at about 6 inches
Haha that was enough to do it
Hehaha
Maybe I should have started off at 6 inches that was more like a foot
And it just crumbles when it hits the rock it just completely disappears
Gotta see that again
There's the drop
And booom
That's amazing yup no explosion it just completely disintegrates and the lid keeps falling at the same rate that's very cool
So why would you even use a cookie jar for a vacuum chamber well for me its just to be able to see inside and look at the reactions going on
You could spend hundreds of dollars  on big professional glass bell jars that are designed for that purpose
But after testing here today I personally be pretty comfortable moving forward with glass cookie jars from now on
As long as you're not dinging them denting, throwing rocks at them or hitting them with hammers
They should hold up relatively well
But that doesn't mean you shouldn't wear safety equipment
It's good to be prepared
So there you have it guys it looks like I'm not going home with any extra holes in my body today so I think we can call it a successful test
It's really cool to see just what happens when a glass vacuum chamber implodes
And don't worry about this mess we will be cleaning it up before we leave
Hey thanks for joining me in this experiment I'll be looking for you in the next one talk to you then
Hey guys thanks for watching and remember I'm giving away prizes now on every new video
All you have to do to qualify is subscribe to my channel, ring the bell and select to be notified when my next videos get released
The secret link to my giveaways will be pinned in the comments for the first twelve hours
If you like what I'm doing show your support right now by giving this video a big thumbs up and share with a friend
I love you back and I'll see you next time
:)